right so they're heading is applications
of differentiating logs log functions
what we had a look at yes they please
help me remember if you differentiate
the just the stock standard natural log
of X what's our answer your the next
step is yeah you're going more
complicated this is just regular X go
Ahead's right okay this is log base e
but when I differentiate that what do I
get
it's an always finish like you go ahead
whatever X thank you okay leashes like
I've known this it's so in there okay
now we can go a little more specifically
because as you might recall one over X
this graph very very roughly you know it
looks like this but this is a problem
because I don't actually want all of
that graph as the derivative of this
which part do I really want
I want the part on the right hand side
yeah because this part over here is the
part that is relevant to the log curve
log curve doesn't exist for X is less
than zero so I actually need to add
something on his remember I need to
include I'll give you a clue it starts
with a curly brace for X is greater than
zero and that's the domain as straight
is it excellent ok now I'll get to the
spot Taiyo is that Hughes like three
steps ahead that's okay when you take
something which isn't just log X if you
differentiate something like log the
function of X something else something
more complicated like you could chuck in
x squared in there or you could chuck a
trig function whatever you like right
what did we get it was a it was a
fraction just like the other ones come
on Tyler I know you know it good friend
very good f dash X find FX now I didn't
make as big a deal about it because you
learn a whole bunch of new concepts
yesterday but I'm serious see how we're
saying X is greater than zero for this
well doesn't that imply we might have a
similar issue over here we're also going
to have a domain restriction how to
think what domain restriction might make
sense
hmm okay let me just leave that play for
a second if you haven't already open
your laptop up get desmos out and let's
um let's just do a quick example okay so
here's an example let's think about the
answer algebraically first because you
can just use this rule and then we'll
use desmos to help us interpret like
what should we put in here okay so
firstly f dash on F excuse me in this
context what's F it's right there I've
written it straight out it's x squared
minus four that's the inside function so
I'm just going to chuck that on the
denominator no changes required on the
top in this case f dash is just 2x
excellent okay fantastic now go ahead in
desmos I want you to give me two graphs
and you could put them on top of each
other go ahead and graph this our
original function
log of x squared minus four and then I
also want you to graph this guy can you
do that for me
log of x squared minus four and then I'd
love you to graph the part that you
think it's derivative should take what
are you looking at well I've got um I've
got two graphs here ones green ones
purple and you've got the same ones in
front of you which one is this one which
one of the graphs is this one
is it it's the green one right let me go
and hide there you go so there's my log
of x squared minus 4 now before we leave
the discussion of this I want you to
notice the log of X square minus 1 is
doing something weird that regular log
doesn't do here's regular log right
here's the regular log curve log of x
squared minus 4 it's got two bits do you
notice that have a look closely why does
it have two bits it's getting negative
values hold on I thought we said you're
not allowed to take logs of negative
numbers how come this one can oh those
are fighting words for someone who
wasn't here yesterday and you learn this
stuff I just returned that in here that
in fact Zack is Craig Zaki can you say
that again one more time for everyone
okay so if you take a negative number
and put it in here that [ __ ] number
gets squared out if it's big enough for
example if you put in negative three
here right negative three or squared
what is it it's negative 3 all squared
it's 9 take away four that's five
positive number all good okay so thank
you top so for that reason when you take
this and then you compare it to its
derivative so now we've got this guy
mine's purple yours might be blue or red
or something like that okay it's got a
problem what's the problem have a look
have a look at it closely you've got in
front of you right
okay just hold on a second year 12 you
12 I'm just hitting pause because this
is hard this is hard stuff I will
promise you I'll put money on the table
in two months yeah two months some of
you will ask this question you want to
know the answer cuz you can't work it
out yourself we're telling you now
remember what I told you about memory
doing that lesson remember I gave you
sin I remember the quote memory is the
residue of what it's what's left behind
when you think about something memory is
the residue of thought I can tell you
right now because I can see it on your
faces what you're thinking about and for
like 50% of you it's this for the other
50% of you it's not you're not gonna
remember this you're not gonna learn it
now I'm actually kind of okay with that
so long as you are but I don't know that
you are so can we try this again
what do you think you - uh Wow like a
non-response you really that okay let's
try this it
are we ready to try this again that's
better thank you okay now what we
compared was this guy and this guy have
a look at it on desmos right this is the
weird wiggly one it sort of has this
like weird s-bend looking thing in the
middle right we don't want that part it
shouldn't exist this doesn't exist there
so the derivative also shouldn't exist
there here's what we need to say that
part that you have on the inside of your
log that's going to be greater than 0
just like this in this case here it
would be x squared minus 4 being greater
than 0 not going to do this as a full
lesson for you can put it in if you like
you don't know what des mots will do
with this but I can tell you what this
is equivalent to is
x is less than negative two x is greater
than positive two and that's sure enough
is that the actual part of the graph
that exists for the original